[Music]
go to kuala lude app inshallah the app
tracks versus pages and time spent
reading and the verses to pages function
takes you from reading a few verses a
day to a few pages a day this project is
for the real enthusiasts if there's
enough of us out there this will become
the future of quran apps and support the
project if you can inshaallah may allah
bless all of you jazakallahu
how are you guys doing i've recently
stumbled across a video
which is entitled why is there something
rather than nothing
this question of course is one of the
most pervasive ones
and one of the most deep ones and one of
those ultimate ones to use a carl
popparian term
that plagues the human species so i want
to listen to what this person say and
see
i think he's coming from an atheist
background of course
how we can comment on some of his
conclusions
all right so there's a kid out with his
dad one day in the forest and the kid
says why the leaves green
and his dad who's a botanist or a tree
surgeon or something says well because
of chlorophyll chlorophyll is green and
leaves have chlorophyll in them and the
kid says
ah-ha and they walk a little more and
the kid says but why is chlorophyll
green the father says
well light bounces off things
differently sometimes and if chlorophyll
is a certain density blah blah or
something so it's green and the kid says
okay
and they walk a bit more and the kid
says but why does light work like that
then and the dad says jesus christ
because that's how physics works
and the kid says but why does physics
work like that and the dad says because
that's how the universe was set up 13
billion years ago when time and space
began all right aristotle leave it alone
already here have a sandwich shut up and
the kid eats his sandwich and he looks
about a bit and they walk a bit more and
the sun's going down and heading back to
the car and the kid says then why did
time and space begin
and that is a pretty good question
everything has a beginning however weird
or wonderful there weren't always
planets or stars or galaxies everything
had to come from something didn't it
well sure it does 13 billion years ago
we're told the universe just appeared
and it was very simple just atoms and
the molecules and chemistry and stars
and then planets and then ecosystems and
then curious sounds and irritated
fathers quite a bit later but how did it
all start there's two answers here
aren't there see everything either came
out of nothing for no reason at all or
everything has always been around well
forever
and both options are
absolutely mental and one of them has to
be true that's a false dichotomy
it's not the case
that either everything came from nothing
or
that everything was just there
there is of course
another option
which you have
quietly
and cheekily
circumnavigated haven't you
which is that for every
dependent thing composed of
parts there is a
composer
putting out the way
everything
made of pieces
everything made of pieces
is dependent the universe is made of
pieces and therefore the universe
is dependent
of course if it's dependent it can
either be dependent on something which
is dependent or dependent on something
which is independent
if it's dependent on something which is
independent
then the job has been done in fact
we have been able to establish the
existence of an independent entity
through which all other entities depend
on
and
if it's dependent on something which is
dependent then you have a series of
dependent things and such a series will
be made up of its constituent parts
and everything made up of constituent
parts is composed
and a series of such multiverses if you
want to put in that language
would be compose
would be made up of parts and therefore
such a series would be composed
so
it's incontrovertible actually
it's inescapable my friend
instead of postulating something which
is actually nonsensical which is that
the
universe came from nothing
something which even the ancients didn't
dare utter from their mouths
in the ancient period and hellistic
period and up until the enlightenment
period
you have
postulated it
you can't prove that on a priori or a
poster or a grounds you can't
prove that cosmologically at all
in fact it's impossible mathematically
so why even mention it as an option
in fact the quran
the book that you should read i would
say
once you've finished eating the pot
noodle
dinner that you have
maybe after a session
in the cellar or you know
watching some illicit stuff or whatever
it is that
you know atheists dudes who quite
frankly or people that don't believe in
god
quite frankly people that do believe in
god as well
you know after you've done what you need
to do and you're maybe understanding
then start contemplating this question
properly why is there something rather
than nothing
it's not that
oh it's it could be from nothing and
that's actually a possibility that's an
impossibility
and if you're saying that well the
universe was always here even that
postulation itself doesn't solve the
problem
because was it here inexplicably
did it give preponderance to itself
um indeed one could say that even if
that were the case and it was here
inexplicably inexplicably
what was it dependent on
once again the question that will plague
you
was it dependent or independent
think about it
and if it was dependent was it dependent
on something that was dependent or was
it dependent on something that was
independent if it was independent if
it's dependent on something that's
independent the job is done then there's
something that's independent if it's
dependent on something which is
dependent then we make the same argument
as we have before so your dichotomy your
foster economy may work on your charms
and friends but it will not work on me
other answers that will not win the cash
prize include one god did it
well well it won't win the cash prize
but i tell you what won't win the cash
prize okay
is your explanation
that nothing which is defined as the
absence of something
can in any way shape or form even
conceivably i'm not saying that you've
said
that it can but it conceivably bring
about something
you think that's gonna win the cash
prize so you can go you get yourself
another pot noodle
hmm
and eat that pot noodle
two i don't care yes you do the stuffing
made of is 13 billion years old too you
should give a damn or three maybe we're
just too stupid to work it out which is
what everyone says shortly before
someone works something out so
everything came from nothing or
everything has always been around well
which one makes more sense
okay then let's say everything came from
nothing so there's nothing and for no
reason at all the universe just well
appeared well weird stuff happens in the
world all the time nothing itself or
non-existence
can only be understood
in reference to existence
if i were to ask you a question and say
to you
imagine non-existence
what is this nothing you talk about
just imagine it what are you going to
imagine what an empty
space for you to imagine an empty empty
space
then you will have to make reference to
the idea of space
thus i may say nothing or non-existence
is unintelligible without reference
to something
just as zero is unintended
unintelligible the number zero
is unintelligible
without clear reference to natural
numbers
and negative numbers so what is this
nothing you speak of apparently no
reason why can't the universe have just
come around like that too
well it's different see when you get a
freak tax rebate or someone crashes into
you at a junction it might seem random
but there is a cause it's just so
complicated that you can't fathom it one
thing follows another and another and
another and another and another and then
whatever happens happens so what does
that have to do with everything coming
from nothing well if there's nothing
there's nothing nothing can't cause
anything everything in the world that
happens is because of atoms bumping into
other atoms well actually they never
touch but that's a story for another
time and fields interacting with other
fields nothing doesn't have atoms or
feels it's nothing
so what then there's black and more
black not even black actually just
nothing and then for no reason at all
there's something you see there you have
it you said it yourself
not not even black anything you said
black and then you realize oh black is
something not even black anything
nothing okay
what is nothing
once again you have nothing to reference
it ironically you know
whenever you want to speak of nothing
you have to reference it
or you have to make reference to
something in existence what is this
nothing you speak of
final reason just pop and now comes the
universe
but that's mad nothing can be without a
cause well here are some fun ideas
though
time is drunk what if time can double
back on itself what if the universe was
caused from its own future there's still
a cause there's still an effect it's
just that the bang came first and then
the cause caused it much later maybe at
the end of time
but that's mental nothing could go
backwards in time can it if you could
kill your own grandfather paradoxes etc
etc etc
maybe modern physics might allow for it
the universe might not care about time
going backwards as long as everything
matches up if someone leaves a winning
lottery ticket on your doorstep and you
win the lottery go back in time and
leave it on your own doorstep to do it
again what's wrong with that as long as
you don't change anything everything is
conserved all the eyes are dotted he's
across no paradoxes no problem
he's talking about something called
retro causality now this can be rejected
on a priori grounds meaning
that the logical form that this would
necessitate would necessitate a
contradiction
for example take a b and c as
a linear
um sequence of some sorts
a causes b b equals a c and c equals a
c would be effectively caused by a if
this were the case and so c would be the
cause of itself
or a would be the cause by itself so
causes would be their own cause and
effects will be their own effect which
is exactly logically impossible
on l1 if you're on a propositional logic
and on s5 or s4 which is modal logic
it's something which is on a priori
grounds to be rejected now i want to say
something
the fact that you've made this claim in
one of itself
shows me the extent to which you are
running away from the inescapable
conclusion the quran itself
states
where they created from themselves
were they created from nothing or
whether they themselves
created of themselves
so you're trying your best you've
literally tried to exhaust these options
these two options which are impossible
options which the quran states
you've tried your best to exhaust these
options only to be to hit a brick wall
why don't you start considering the real
logical options
you couldn't have been created from
nothing that's ridiculous and you
probably recognized that yourself and
you couldn't create yourself
not only because
of causality but because of dependence
we talked about causality already
causality is defined as something which
brings rise to phenomena but dependence
is different to causality because
dependence is something which relies
upon something else
now it's conceivable that something can
cause something but not that thing does
not depend upon it if i have a son and
he has a son
my grandson will be caused by me
yes but he doesn't depend on me for
continued existence now it would be
absurd even if you wanted to
argue for retro causality of the
creation of the universe it's absurd to
us
to estimate that there is a continued
reliance of the universe on itself
unless you want to say that the universe
is independent and if you say that then
you've come away from atheism you've
left the pale of atheism my friend and
then you have become a deist but i will
say to you arguing reductio that in fact
that's impossible because the universe
is composed of parts and we said
anything compose a parts is dependent
and the universe is composed of parts
therefore the universe is dependent but
what is it dependent on is it depend
upon something that's dependent or
something that's independent it would
have to be dependent upon something
that's independent because if it's
dependent on something that's dependent
then there'll be a series of dependent
things if you want to say ad infinitum
say so but then that series itself will
be composed of parts and everything
compose the past is dependent and
therefore the multiverse is in the is
dependent it is composed of parts and
therefore the universe is dependent
therefore you really have to uh and so
do the atheist community step up their
game this is not good enough of all due
respect this honestly infuriates me that
someone is willing to sacrifice their
own logical
uh ability yeah they were they're able
to affront their own
they're able to embarrass their own
sense of
decency and common sense by making
arguments like this why don't you just
wake up
yeah and think properly i want to say to
you honestly the earth is coming enough
is enough
your day is done
the new atheist uh
vogue the the new atheist wave has has
now
subsided we must say
think properly i honestly think properly
enough is enough
it's not that you were created from
nothing as i've said
and it's not that you yourself are the
creators of yourself it's not that the
universe was created from nothing and
it's not that the universe universe
itself was a creator of itself these two
things are impossibilities
think about the other option and i know
what you know
and i know that you know what the other
option is what's up
[Music]
you